[Music]
get those bingo cards ready folks hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by karma and
we'll be reviewing
julianne huff's harper's bazaar what i
eat in a day
because this one was so obviously
abby review material it made the top
comment
on her video so yeah i wouldn't let you
down
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor karma
so karma formerly known as shoptagger
is an online chrome extension that
allows you to save money
on the things you are already buying
with no additional effort from you
so you can click on the link in my
description box to download the
extension
and app i actually use the karma
extension to save some money on my last
2 am skin care purchase so i'm already
feeling much better about my midnight
buys but it's also been a great way to
save on things that i
really need like diapers and food for
the kids
basically all you have to do is just
download the chrome extension
from the google chrome store and then
while you're shopping online
at one of your favorite online stores
you can save the products you want
and let karma look for deals then
you'll instantly get a notification in
your email
or phone when an item that you've been
looking at and
saved goes on sale has a relevant coupon
that you can use
or comes back in stock you can also
organize your favorite products into
wishlist so that you can
shop more mindfully and avoid those
impulse buys
and yikes your girl can definitely
use that so one great feature that karma
offers is that it scans the web for
coupon codes
and then applies them at checkout
immediately
this feature is only available on
desktop so
downloading the extension on your
computer is a must
you can also earn cash via paypal when
you shop from select retail partners
so that is another huge plus as well so
if you want to try out karma yourself
check out the link in my description and
on screen and of course
don't forget to check out my disclaimer
on screen and in the description below
including a trigger warning to those
with current or past
disordered eating histories there is a
lot of potential
triggering diet culture talk in this
video so
feel free to skip it if it's not
supportive to your journey also don't
forget to subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on an episode
all righty folks get those dye culture
bs big note cards ready because
they're gonna fill up real quick i'm not
even sure there's a game here
honestly this video feels like cheating
let's take a look i
drink my lemon water that i've prepped
the night before and
that usually consists of lukewarm
temperature water with a half a lemon
and sitting overnight really getting all
those juices
oh well this is extra uh
not only are we having of course lemon
water
but it's just so time consuming to make
lemon water
we apparently got a meal prep it the
night before
not only is this inconvenient but it's
actually
not a great idea to leave out any fruit
infused water
at room temperature overnight even with
the acidity from the lemon
this can potentially become a bacterial
breeding ground
especially if you leave lemon slices
with the skin
in there as well and even if it doesn't
make you sick
letting it sit out will change the color
flavor
and possibly also the nutritional
benefits
since lemons are subject to oxidation
in heat and light so yeah
please don't take advice on julianne's
make-ahead lemon water regimen
the reason why i take it first thing in
the morning is anything that was kind of
left residue from the night before i can
take that lemon water and feel
like i'm cleaning my system out starting
with a fresh palette for the day
uh nope nope nope nope
no no no no no it doesn't clean out the
residue
from the night before i honestly do not
know what kind of
residue julianne has inside her but she
makes it sound like she's like
a sticky mac and cheese baked onto a
casserole dish
in a dish detergent commercial a lot of
folks ask me why their dishwasher
doesn't get everything clean
i tell them lemon water our insides
they're gonna be okay
they don't need lemon water to clean
anything out
any water will help to move your bowels
and promote
natural detoxing so i guess if
a little lemon makes it taste better to
you great
squeeze that in but focusing on some
fiber
and any kind of water will do the rest
celery juice or something that also
gives me a little bit of sugar before i
go uh
do a quick workout or i'll do like amino
acids or something like that to just
give me that
support that energy that i'm looking for
wow
wow so many problematic statements in
like five seconds of footage
okay first of all i would never
characterize
celery juice as a source of sugar
to energize your workout
there's literally one gram of carbs in a
stock of celery
one a banana in contrast which would be
a very
very modest pre-workout snack and also
not something that i would characterize
as super high in carbs and sugar has 30.
so please let's stop the carb-shaming
crap here
second branch-chain amino acids are
exactly that
amino acids the building blocks of
protein
and as such they are also not the most
efficient source of energy and since
we're on the topic of amino acids
i just want to remind everyone that if
you're consuming
enough protein from whole protein
sources
or even from like a protein powder
there's no need for additional
bcaas or branched chain amino acid
supplements
they also contain so few calories aka
energy because that's what calories are
that they are not going to be very good
fuel for a hard
workout either i drink coffee not
because i feel like i need it but
because i
love the ritual of having something warm
that smell and i just love the taste of
coffee
i'm technically not supposed to have
coffee so it is like a special treat for
me
if i do have coffee um anyone else feel
like
judged by julianne saying she doesn't
need
coffee as if she's better than all of us
exhausted adults out here who cannot
manage to
get anything done without a strong cup
of joe
i eat coffee just me
anyways i digress i also love
the ritual of a cup of coffee so much so
that i drink decaf late morning
not because it does anything for me
stimulant-wise
but because it actually helps signify
some sense of peace and relaxation to me
i'm not sure why she said she's not
supposed to have it
i know it sounds like a self-imposed
food rule to me
but i will give her the benefit of the
doubt that
there's a good reason so in return i
will do
a matcha tea or a matcha latte that's
sort of my
other cozy favorite otherwise i try to
stick to herbal teas
okay so matcha also has caffeine just
fyi
but as i've discussed in detail in a
bunch of my other videos
it generally gives a more slower more
steady release of energy
rather than a quick hit of caffeine like
espresso would
herbal teas are also a great way to get
your water in for the day so
that sounds good to me but speaking of
water
i love soup so i will usually make
a lot and freeze it i also love a good
soup
before i gave birth i made like 20
different varieties of soup and
i stocked my freezer full and even
in like a really hot summer i'm all
about the soup and
yes for folks out there who are stressed
trying to meet their arbitrary
water quota for the day please know that
fluids
from things like tea and soup totally do
count i'm really big on variation so i
don't eat the same thing
every day and that's great i mean you
know that i am
all about variety because it ensures
that we get a nice range of micro
and macronutrients over time to best
meet our needs
a butternut squash soup with carrot and
this is like
the ayurvedic way so all plant-based
and uh vegan okay that sounds like a
delicious soup
love butternut squash and carrot but
probably not super filling on its own
so one thing that i like to do with
pureed vegetable based soups like this
is i like to add in a can of rinsed
white beans to just
bump up the protein and fiber and you
just puree that right in
as well now i'm not sure exactly what is
the ayurvedic way
about this soup but if we look at the
ayurvedic
principles and how they're sometimes
applied to food we often see a
great emphasis on soups and warm foods
for folks who identify with the veda
dosha
having said that there is also no
evidence to support the concept of
doshas or that
certain personality traits determine
which foods you should eat
so i really respect the rich history of
ayurvedic medicine
but at this point the personalized diet
recommendations that
a lot of these wellness gurus promote
are just not evidence-based
for my salad i'm going to keep it really
fresh
with some asparagus broccolini some
beets
watermelon radishes with some ginger on
top
over a bed of spinach some of the
dressings that i really like to use
apple cider vinegar it helps the
digestion first and foremost
if i'm lucky i'll find some sort of like
gluten-free cracker
uh if she's lucky please tell me how
could a girl get
said luck doesn't she have the financial
access to
like a sleeve of crackers i'm confused
okay so
if she was trying to avoid gluten but
couldn't get
lucky on the gluten-free cracker front
she could also
add in some quinoa or rice
both of which would add some energizing
carbs and fiber and
are naturally gluten free i would also
love to see this salad
beefed up with some source of protein
whether that's some like tofu
or beans or legumes or whatever as for
the apple cider vinegar for digestion
claim
honestly it's a little bit of a stretch
the theory is that apple cider vinegar
increases the acidity of the stomach
which helps your body
create more pepsin which is the enzyme
that breaks down protein
now while we have no research to support
the use of vinegar for digestion
we do know that other acidic digestion
supplements like
betaine hcl can increase the acidity of
the stomach so
theoretically it's totally possible but
most
experts believe you would need to be
taking a few tablespoons
before a meal to have any kind of major
impact
so whether or not there's enough in a
vinaigrette to
have an impact we do not know but
speaking of the vinaigrette
i do hope it is a vinaigrette and not
just
straight up vinegar because yeah this
salad could
desperately use some fat for satiety
flavor
and to improve the absorption of a lot
of the nutrients from all that veg
and by the way i sound so la right now
with all this gluten-free dairy-free
vegan but it's because my body needs it
because trust me
do i love flour i love sugar i love
cookies i love all the things but i'm
really just trying to focus on my health
from the inside out
well this right here says it all first
of all
i fully appreciate that some people's
bodies
need to be gluten-free or dairy-free or
maybe even completely plant-based
fine if you feel better when you put
almond creamer in your coffee instead of
milk then it's going to be
advantageous for you to use the creamer
but i believe
focusing on your health from the inside
is largely about mental and physical
health
it's about joy and pleasure and actually
sometimes
not focusing so intently on your health
in the sense that these thoughts are not
dominating your life
and that means sometimes just having
some cookies
or adding some crackers or bread to your
salad so of course if gluten does not
feel good to you
choose a gluten-free cookie and seek out
gluten-free crackers
i know you have the means julianne so
this shouldn't be a question of
getting lucky by throwing one in listen
it's 2021 and there's a lot wrong with
the world
and with the food industry specifically
but one thing we can all be grateful for
is that there are a plethora of options
out there for folks
with dietary restrictions who still want
to
enjoy life and enjoy food so if you're
using your food intolerances
as a reason why you can only eat low
calorie
clean foods then you really need to be
honest with yourself
and your intention and i suggest doing a
really deep dive
to evaluate your relationship with food
all right dinner time
i have this mung doll that i've prepared
and free crackers
some toasted black sesame seeds and then
of course i'm gonna make some
sides as well so we've got sweet potato
asparagus
some ginger collard greens uh swiss
chard spinach
this is really nourishing really yummy i
feel really full by the end of it
now this sounds like a really delicious
meal
so mung dal is a indian dish made of
stewed
yellow hmong lentils uh super high in
fiber
and protein and definitely really
satiating
so paired with the carbs in the sweet
potato and the crackers
fiber in the greens and fat in the
sesame seeds
i would say this is a beautifully
balanced
cozy meal so more like this please
making sure that i'm still
having pleasure with my food throughout
the day i
either choose to have a glass of wine or
a cocktail
which speaking of this is one of my
favorite wines
it's my wine with my best friend nina
that's usually what i like to do
to cap off my really nourishing day
ah so here's julianne's pleasure
you know it's funny because this
interview played out exactly
like nina dobrov's uh one would think
that they have an undisclosed
partnership with harper's bazaar
to plug their wine product so yeah it's
like eat really clean all day
then splurge on wine but only this
specific wine made by me and my bff of
course
let's be real if reality tv is any
indicator of
real life in hollywood i just feel like
this is kind of the la way
now i'll be honest i have always been
more enthusiastic about
eating my calories than drinking them
but
i also fully appreciate that a lot of
people straight up
prefer a liquid dessert so leave me a
comment below if your preference
would be you know dessert or wine if you
could only have one
i'm just kind of curious where we net
out but also i don't know who needs to
hear this
but it's okay to have a glass of wine
and
other pleasurable foods in your day a
glass of red or white wine has only like
125 calories
nothing to write home about in the
context of a day like julianne's which
is
chock full of vegetables and honestly
not a whole lot else
there is 100 room for more pleasure in
fact if i were her dietitian
i would say please girl i get that
you're vegan
gluten-free and dairy-free but there are
thousands of delicious ways to live your
days
and they don't need to require living
off of pureed and raw vegetables all day
just to relish in a glass of wine at
five o'clock
you are worthy of more than one
enjoyable eating episode in your day
eating doesn't have to be a chore that
you do to earn yourself
wine especially when you get said wine
for free okay
motivational speech over let's see what
she has to say everything in moderation
and if you love your body and you
love what you're putting into your body
your body's gonna know so if you're
already telling yourself oh i shouldn't
be eating this and
then your body's gonna have that stress
and hold on to it so
if you're gonna do something if you're
gonna drink if you're gonna have a
yummy sweet tooth then enjoy it
so yes exactly
but is it just me or do those words
and what we all just witnessed in this
interview
not compute i mean i guess that's kind
of the hollywood way though right like
you get so used to the theatrics that
you can make yourself believe that
you're doing things
and you can tell other people you're
doing things that you are
absolutely not doing yourself this is
awkward
so yeah what can we say about julianne's
diet there's not a whole lot to see here
folks
we've got water and celery juice and
vegetable soup
and vegetable salad and a vegetable
based stew
with some legumes but mostly just
vegetables oh we also have some wine
that we profit off of selling so yeah
obviously we got to plug that
now you guys know obviously i think all
plants are great
especially the plants that give you a
buzz but a girl
cannot and should not live on
vegetables and booze alone i would
love to see more carbs more fat and more
protein in this day
especially because the girl is a
professional dancer
she needs more calories she needs more
food what's perhaps even
more problematic than the sparse menu
here
is the side of obvious wellness culture
calling coffee a treat
suggesting she needs to get lucky to
have a gluten-free cracker with her
vegetable only
salad and saying she loves cookies but
she doesn't need cookies because she's
focusing on her health
are all at odds with her little
everything in moderation
pep talk at the end of this video it's
as if she's hoping that
sliding in that little disclaimer would
completely nullify
all of the wellness culture bs that she
just spewed at us
when in fact it just made her feel even
less relatable and sincere i mean i
should have assumed her food pov
would look like this after her brother's
video which i reviewed right here
and i wouldn't have been so mad about it
if she didn't try to pass off a glass of
the wine that she produces
as evidence of a healthy relationship
with food and
moderation if this is what truly feels
good to julianne
great but i just don't want her
impressionable young fans to
think this is what moderation or even
what indulging
looks like and that they can't have a
glass of wine
if they treat themselves to like a
coffee that day
i'm getting welled up on that note
closing this off for today so that
i can go have a drink myself a big thank
you to karma for sponsoring this video
if you liked it please be sure to give
it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye